hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play ghouls forest
3d now I know that says ghoul 3d but
it's actually ghouls forest 3d which is
a remake in 3d of ghouls forest which is
a mod for doom so this is a mod of a mod
little mod ception going on there but
this is supposed to be pretty terrifying
now I've never
oh hello I've never played the original
ghouls forest I'm just gonna stand in
okay I'm just gonna stand in the middle
of fire come at me you demon bastards
now I've never played the original
ghouls forest but I heard it was pretty
scary even for a doom mod so it's just
it's just supposed to be like this I
can't even see a damn thing outside of
my circle of fire here how am I supposed
to who's that what the hell okay loading
up my bow good thing I practiced so much
from probably our joy what where where
where what what what what what is it
what is it what is it what am I looking
about what am i no Numa okay is it
behind me I can't tell where it is I
can't see it what's going on what's
going on here I can't see a damn thing
I've wandered into the woods oh this is
bad what the hell is going on what the
hell's coming what the hell's going on
God
kill you [ __ ] ass oh oh no oh no oh
no this is gonna be one of those games
Oh No what ha ha ha ha to be it's
another Gaga one game ok you son of it
I'm gonna prime this and I'm just gonna
be firing this off it random direction
tone no oh yeah that's is that different
I can tell is it different good
now go get me whatever the [ __ ] you are
I don't care you go get back
I got a bow I hit all those targets and
probably Archer oh my god it was not a
smart idea to crank up my volume on this
game yeah I hear yo I don't see you but
I hear you I don't see you but I hear
you do some like a flashlight or
something anything that what is that
what is that it's it's girl I'm gonna
shoot to piss outta ya
oh you're gonna close all yeah hmm huh
oh yeah yeah yeah
what the hell know what this is way hand
there we go oh I got it right between
the eyes
why isn't it dying nah load your bow
yeah ah I get it
did I get it I think I got it looks like
I'm one I think I got it okay I got I
think I got it guys
ok I think I got it all right okay all
right okay all right okay all right okay
all right okay I hear uh something ah ah
well I can't go I did it I got it
those that thing from before I didn't I
got it I got it I think I got okay sorry
about that the game crashed on me I
guess it's a little buggy ha ha I think
I was about to win him hot [ __ ] oh okay
all right we're back in here come on
bring it on bring it on you [ __ ] I
killed you already I'm gonna kill you
again and I'm gonna get up here and I
better win I'm gonna win I'm gonna win
okay anyway so everybody hushed your
face for a few seconds already how's
your face
what's your face how's your face hush
okay no don't you whatever the hell you
are you died you died a fire my god you
died you died
dinah fire fire dad um i getcha I got
you didn't I
I gotcha that's cuz I got you good
that's cuz I shot you in the face okay
good good good
oh I hear you I hear you I hear you
where are you quit hang on wait oh wait
I'm zoning in I'm honing in on you come
on rip ow
oh god I hit a tree I didn't mean to I
hit a tree I was trying to back up I hit
a tree
okay let's try this again whoa oh oh
it's not a good sound it's not a good
sound where's it coming from where's it
coming from
what's gumbo driver where's he coming
from I don't know got my ball ready with
a cup of ramen I don't know where it's
coming from
hello who's coming hello it's cover
oh I was more freaked out that it was
about to get me then when it actually
caught me oh no idea why I don't like
that one that was my least favorite of
all the bunch okay
go on fire stomp you out I stomp you out
good I stopped out to fire okay I don't
like that one either let's just go ahead
and say I don't like any of them where
is it where is it I don't see it
oh my ball ready but I know I can't get
my boat ready get fired by boat I kept
our bow but do you bow
I couldn't find my bow come on bring it
on skull bastard will kill you dead
then we'll sleep in your bed rub your
head where are you there yeah right see
you man
it takes three hits to kill you ma'am
[ __ ] ah John I was on a tree again I'm
not gonna get caught on a tree this time
ha ha ha come on
second fire all right good one more come
on come on yah yah
gah gah killed you dead hahahahaha
I don't like that one okay where I where
are ya where are you I don't know where
this one's coming from because it sounds
like it's all around me okay
alright I think it's okay I'm ready for
you come on come on come on I thought it
really wait yeah there you are I see you
yeah BAM one shot oh no no no no no no -
shot no no no no no three shots yeah why
no ha one shot Oh get away
two shots okay no no trees okay come on
come on yeah got you got you you're dead
all right oh no not this one hey that's
one where are you where are you wait
wait okay I think wait no it's hard to
tell where this one coming from cuz it
sounds I fit better be in front of me
this time it better be in frickin front
of me that's all I gotta say
better be freaking it's on the ground
boys I look it up okay I'm done done
I've done as buggies this game was
I don't like it I don't like it anymore
I don't wanna play anyway okay I'm done
thank you all for watching do you want
to play it for yourself see if there's
an actual ending that you can get to
click the link in the description below
thank you everybody for watching oh my
god clicking a taste for me is it I've
done it as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
Oh
comment what is that dagger